the world war one movie 1917 is being
called an instant Oscar frontrunner I
agree watched it last night it tells the
story of two young British soldiers on a
dangerous mission through enemy lines to
save hundreds of lives Oscar winner that
Sam Mendes directed produced and
co-wrote the movie which was inspired by
his war hero grandfather start my
couture trays Lance Corporal Scofield
who embarks on the life or death journey
with his friend Blake in this clip the
two soldiers are trying to escape from a
booby-trapped German bunker
some boy shot
you're going to have to jump just jump
trust me 19:17 just earned three Golden
Globe nominations including Best Drama
and best director Sam Mendes and George
McKay are with us you both of you good
morning welcome thanks for being here
Sam this this film is really a tribute
to your grandfather
Alfred direct who was in World War one
that's right he enlisted as a 17 year
old and but he never talked about his
experiences in the war even to his own
children and he was a message carrier
what was he he was he carried it well
that was one of the things he was asked
at him because he was very small he was
five and a half feet yeah and the mist
hung at six feet in no-man's land in the
winter they sent him with messages so he
couldn't be seen above the top of the
mist by the enemy Wow yeah that he was
17 and he never spoke about until his
70s and but he happened to speak about
it with his grandchildren and then when
he told you you thought there was a
story here is that yeah it's an 11 year
old I'm gonna make a movie about no
actually I okay okay well he was his
story yes of mine to tell in a way it
was only later after making movies that
and beginning to have the courage to
write my own that I thought that was the
story that I wanted to tell what if that
man who was kind of just kept going so
and there's there you are George because
this is a thing I'm not necessarily a
fan of war movies but what I like this
to me was more of a human story the
struggle the struggle of these two and
experienced soldiers who were trying to
deliver this really life-and-death
message in real time and for you it
meant what yeah completely agree I think
I think war is unequivocally the context
for it but it's like it's it's an arena
in which humans are stretched to their
absolute limits you know like physically
emotionally and then therefore kind of
what you come back to I think that's
that's what it was for me anyhow yeah
visually it's a very unique experience
right you get a sense of it from the
clip we saw but the whole movie in fact
has many more scenes where there's a
long unbroken camera shot and I was
learning ahead of time that you actually
had the actors in the beginning walk all
the scenes do their lines and then you
built the set around their natural paces
why'd you do it that way well because
it's one continuous shot it's two hours
of real time and I wanted the audience
to experience those two hours exactly as
the characters do I wanted them to feel
every second passing take every step
the journey with with the characters and
feel the physical difficulty of the
journey so the challenge was then we had
to make everything join up the it's one
long set and and of course when the set
is landscape farm houses towns at night
canals tranches you have to measure
everything we didn't build a trench
until we knew exactly the scene we were
trying to build it for so we build over
a mile of trenches you know and we even
had to measure the river that he gets
into how did you do that because there's
a calorie of it all and they said I read
that you insisted on doing your own
stunts you know you could add somebody
do that for you why did you want to do
it yourself it's a mixture of like it's
one I just want to be involved as much
as possible and to this you know when
the camera doesn't cut there's not too
much chance to swap someone else in
threw him into the river that's the
truth that was audition there's one very
dramatic scene we saw I think a bit of
it before where you were running through
a field and the bombs are going off and
and I was struck by the fact that that's
that's not CGI you had what five hundred
extras we did yeah yeah here it's
amazing yeah they are all real
explosions and they are real those are
real they're real human beings CGI -
yeah no no it's real and I take a tumble
as well and that's all you know just
that one actually just happened by
mistake so that was by mistake there's a
few yeah that's the thing is you know
within these like these long sequences
you want to have the kind of unexpected
moments to keep the whole thing alive
what did this movie mean to you this
part mean to you playing this guy I
think well it's an honor to be you know
one to work with Sam and with all the
team to remember all those that fought
and then also kind of what I said that
what the whole thing was about to me is
is you know remembering what's most
important to you you know when you go
when you go through a journey that
properly stretches you
it's then what you come back to there
properly stretches you know like that
Sam how do you think your grandfather
would feel about this film well I think
that he was a storyteller by trade I
mean he was a novelist and I think he
would be proud that an a member of his
family you know ended up telling stories
too but I also think he might have
struggled to watch it as a man who
couldn't talk about it for 60 years so
it would there would have been a certain
we have a name for it now PTSD you know
what we
but I think that you know he putting him
back in the middle of it he might have
struggled with that called the
shell-shocked back then yeah you're
definitely both are definitely in the
Oscar conversation how are we feeling
about that George I think they're like
any kind of buzz around the film that
this is like properly a film to be made
that's made to be seen in the cinema can
see in this enema so that's the best
thing that can come from you know any
sort of buzz around you would agree with
that you've got to see it on a big
screen yeah I mean that's that watch on
your iPhone or your [ __ ] that's why we
made it but you didn't I think I have a
very big television on as big as a movie
screen but it's pretty big I got the
feel thank you how does it George of a
guy thank you thank you
Congrats guys Congrats